avec nos docteurs car vice président de
l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
dr weiss bonsoir bonsoir
alors je vous fais commenté sur
l'actualité d'abord sur les nouvelles
données aujourd'hui on a vu que le taux
de mortalité le taux d'hospitalisation
reste hospitalisation -2 7% mentalité à
peu près 1 pour ça qu'on a ajouté des
gens aujourd'hui sa faim sont les morts
au québec on expliquer parce que des
gens étaient morts depuis un certain
temps mais on n'était pas sûr on les a
mis dans cette catégorie là bref qu'est
ce que ça vous dit les chiffres
aujourd'hui main c'est l'outil que c'est
une maladie qui est sévère et qui est un
problème et y pense que malheureusement
quand on a des morts s'est jamais bien
on peut penser qu'on allait y est
peut-être un peu plus épargnées kyler
hall est sur sa phase aspects on n'est
définitivement pas dans une situation
européenne ou définitivement pas dans la
situation de new york mais
malheureusement il ya des décès et puis
dans ton nez on en aura d'autres encore
ce qui est encore plus malheureux
on a de plus en plus de gens dans les
hôpitaux dans les soins intensifs
on sait que les hôpitaux moi je parle à
mes collègues le sait ce qu'on vit dans
l'hôpital donc je sais que la vague est
en train de monter mais pour l'instant
elle est relativement contenu alors
est-ce qu'il va falloir faire on est pas
on n'est pas au sommet en est loin du
sommet et est-ce qu'il va falloir faire
de façon très importante c'est de
s'assurer que on continue de garder les
mesures qui ont été mises en place par
le ministre le premier ministre de
garder le confinement de garder une
discipline pour minimiser le nombre de
cas alors pour l'instant c'est tout ce
qu'on peut faire quand il faut il faut
essayer de tenir nos lignes puis à être
lézignan et être être je vous dirais
optimiste à long terme
mais passé par des moments difficiles
bon mais vous êtes quand même on est
loin du sommeil quand vous regardez à
l'augmentation des loin du sommet
j'aimerais vous dire ça qu'on est au
sommet mais on voit que le nombre de cas
augmente il faut faire attention avec
les chiffres
c'est qu'on peut pas sur une journée
décider si vous avez vu au québec où
jours
ça va bien journée ça a l'air d'aller
moins bien une journée on a beaucoup de
cas pas beaucoup de morts la journée
suivante on a plus de décès n'est moins
deux cas alors il faut voir des
tendances lourdes et souvent d'ailleurs
souvent c'est comme ça les chiffres 1 en
médecine il faut regarder des tendances
sur quatre jours c'est un jour voir
comment les quatre cinq jours dix ans de
cette semaine ce sont comparés aux 4 5
jours de la semaine dernière et de la
semaine d'avant
et ça ça va nous donner une vision plus
réelle de ce qui s'en vient on de ce qui
va se passer
très bien questions du public dr weiss
j'aimerais savoir si le virus se déplace
dans l'air et si oui sur quelle
superficie doit-on avoir peur du vent le
virus des places dans l'air mais il se
déplace avec des gouttelettes les
gouttelettes on a dit que c'était des
gros substances qui peuvent pas aller
très très loin donc habituellement dans
un rayon d'à peu près six pieds au tour
de celle d'un individu
donc ils se déplacent quand on parle
s'émeut le virus là ce moment la vallée
dans l'air va rester en suspension
quand on éternue quand on tousse le
virus peut aller plus loin parce qu'on
peut générer des aérosols et à ce moment
là ça peut aller beaucoup plus loin donc
ça c'est l'aspect entre guillemets du de
l'aérosol isation du virus en ce qui
concerne les surfaces le virus peut
survivre plusieurs heures sur terre
certaines surfaces
environ 3 4 heures sur des surfaces je
dirais standard mais par exemple
longtemps sur la ti et le plastique
peut-être jusqu'à 24 heures sur du
carton donc le virus peut survivre sur
certaines surfaces dans des conditions
atmosphériques qui sont adéquats bon une
question qu'on a beaucoup reçu on est
faible que le pourcentage de faux
négatifs pour le testerai de 30 pour ça
ce pourcentage semble-t-il réalise pour
le test au québec si oui faut-il s'en
inquiéter et 30% de faux négatifs c'est
très haut c'est parce qu'on voit au
québec
il va déterminer les faux négatifs
souvent c'est si on a mal fait le
prélèvement
c'est à dire si on n'a pas pris assez
d'échantillons pour avoir une bonne su
pour avoir assez de virus dans ce rôle
dans l'échantillon comprend où le fait
qu'on a pris des gens tellement tôt dans
leur maladie ou qui sont totalement
asymptomatique et qui ont pas beaucoup
de virus dont on n'a pas 30 % de faux
négatifs au québec ça c'est clair
bon très bien c'est clair nous sommes un
couple de 85 et 82 en bonne santé et sam
à la maison seuls 24 heures sur 24
est-ce que ça serait contre-indiqué
d'aller faire une randonnée en auto s'en
sortir de l'auto bah écoutez la bonne
chose si vous êtes en santé alors je
vais vous dire de rester en santé et
restez chez vous pour l'instant parce
que bon dès qu'on fait n'importe quoi
vous sortez d'une auto on vous souhaite
pas mais vous avez un accident alors
qu'est ce qui se passe on vous
transporte à l'hôpital vous êtes à
l'hôpital dans un environnement il ya
tête des cas de co vide autour de vous
il me se passer toute sorte de chose
vous avez une panne alors pourquoi
prendre des risques quand vous êtes chez
vous en consumant et que vous êtes en
bonne santé on veut vous garder en bonne
santé
bon voilà vous êtes sages docteur est ce
que c'est vrai que la viande peut être
contaminé si la personne qui la manipule
un étaient contaminés oui mais ce serait
quand même poussé à l'extrême
même la personne se met volontairement a
quasiment tout s'est crashé éternuer sur
la viande et que donc à ce moment-là que
oui aurait des virus sur la viande est
que lorsque vous allez la manipuler
relativement rapidement que vous vous
auto contaminé c'est ce qu'on appelle le
transfert par contact direct ou indirect
mais ce serait quand même peu probable
oui il ya toutes sortes de scénarios les
gens nous je vous donne pas les plus
farfelues ne vous en faites pas mais à
toutes sortes de scénarios que les gens
beaucoup d'imagination faut quand même
le dire
après on a été confronté à beaucoup de
sortes de scénarios dans notre vie de
tous les jours aussi au niveau des
hôpitaux et il a fallu résoudre ces
problèmes là il y en a pas toujours les
solutions
oui tout à fait après quatorze jours la
personne est plus contagieuse
donc si tout le monde reste à la maison
pendant 14 jours sans jamais sortir
nous devrions être corrects demande
brigitte oui mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent être
asymptomatique est porteur il ya des
gens qui peuvent être très peu
symptomatiques dont ils se considèrent
asymptomatique et ils vont quand même
sortir et il ya quand même des services
essentiels qu'on peut pas enlever donc
il reste quand même un parent de la
transmission
et n'oubliez pas
tout ce qu'on voit actuellement c'est
tout ce qui s'est passé il ya saint
geours séjour dix jours à peu près donc
on les gens qui deviennent positifs
aujourd'hui sont des gens qui ont tous
nous disent l'épidémiologie on va dire
d'une semaine à peu près et puis je suis
content j'ai une autre question d'un
enfant de dix ans alexandre colin elle
est bonne pourquoi la coved 19 ans fait
le corps n'avait russes n'aiment pas de
savon on prenne un peu de savon écouter
en réalité c'est que le stade et rue
c'était une enveloppe et le savons ce
que ça fait quand on met du savant sur
ces virus là ça fait un processus qu'on
appelle une saponification c'est à dire
ça détruit cette enveloppe qui entoure
le virus ça va donc la table a brisé et
à ce moment là vous allez brise et
l'intégrité du virus et vous le
détruisent et donc le savons a un effet
bénéfique de détruire l'enveloppent qui
va entourer le virus voilà alexandre des
belges du savon lavage de mains
d'acteurs merci comment se porte
rapidement vos collègues
c'est à l'hôpital juif de montréal très
sollicités comment se portent vos
collègues et vous maintenant tout le
monde se porte garante pour l'instant et
on espère se portait bien longtemps mais
ce que je voudrais c'est que il ya
énormément travail des gens sont
fatigués sinon c'est très stressé quand
les gens disent si vous voulez qu'on
soit là pour vous soyez là pour nous en
restant chez vous très clair restez chez
vous merci à docteur bonne fin de
semaine avoir vos aussi fait savoir